sponsors segment Hoke heck yeah my
favorite part of this channel thank you
everyone now what do you say with me
that's right
brick and balls not brick and bones
brick and falls greatest game of all
time completely impartial opinion okay
brick and vault is a comfortable
addictive and harder than it looks
say it with me comfortable addictive and
harder than it looks
if you have 1,000 ice cubes then this
game is for you because it takes a smart
player goddammit you think you're up for
the challenge
brick and balls how much does this game
cost Felix you can download it for free
do I have to sell this anymore
I don't think so do I assume this game
has already gotten 85 million downloads
or absolutely in the main gameplay there
are thousands of levels to beat
thousands name one other game with
thousand levels it doesn't exist
there's also hundred ball challenge I am
playing right now as we speak
hundred ball challenge where you try and
get as high score as possible with
hundred volts one launch my high score
is 558 try and beat it gravity another
excellent game mode which is an endless
challenge mode with gravitational
gameplay god damn I know I'm not
supposed to give my opinion because this
is a sponsored video but goddamn check
out brick and balls download breaking
balls there are other interesting aspect
of this game to explore for example Ruby
Bank album collection I don't think I
need to say anything else
download brick and box link in
description
thank you breaking balls for sponsoring
this video if you download it and
comment in this video in this video your
high score I will pick one person in the
comments randomly of course that will
win 5000 and the lucky winner will be
selected March 8th brofist I'll give you
a brokerage if you download breaking
balls
[Music]
good job - I see light blue but
sometimes pain - oh yeah then why am I
getting the monitor this is so sad umji
can lick my balls no frills remove the
strikes your dumb ball remove the
strikes your ding Gong Gong don't make
me go further than that now without
further ado let's do into it you're
spunky what are you doing dar you
sniffing spunky spunky this is me this
is literally me when I spat sniffing
smack ass you know spunky what are you
doing dog he's sniffing he's been there
for a while what a great name what a
great time to be alive wasn't there a
South Park episode where they sniff the
cats and they makes them high like cat
piss makes you high or something like
that that's true the people get high
using cat urine in one episode of South
Park yeah here we go
you actually can wait people are saying
no well I guess I'm just gonna have to
try it out it looks like spunky had a
great time okay I haven't had a great
time in a while
pop-up page needs a great time when when
you're terrible is that you can work
with your own with your friend that you
can choose by yourself the crossovers
are so unnecessary at this point I love
it I love it so much
my god everyone's making these now I
mean it looks amazing it looks really
excited like what's your full name
hazel grace Lancaster what are you
looking at me like that because you're
beautiful cool makeup so sweet people
are still making whatever that movie was
called her memes fantastic
it's the anime girl god damn it stopped
up with these stuff with megalovania
stuff with the 2015 means okay let's do
something fresh let's stop making the
same videos over and over again Here I
am trying to innovate bait and all these
kids are just doing the same thing I am
literally complaining but other people
are doing the same thing while doing the
same thing joke explained everyone let's
move on no I mean yes I can't laugh at
that because this is not your life you
lose this is just me criticizing kids
that's right everyone that was great
very good tick tock I hit you sometimes
you gotta appreciate it at least the
tick tock sooner or later these tick
tock kids will become famous some la
agency will say hey you need to sign up
with our crew and then they'll go yeah
no that sounds great
la is great and then they'll sign off
all their videos so that they'll start
claiming this thing tick tock
compilations from all these kids and
there you go tick tock ruins that's what
happened to vine and I'll pretend that
that's wasn't the case okay the only one
that can make videos out of tic toc
videos is me and you mg apparently
[Music]
are you are you kidding me
are you actually kidding me stop it stop
with with a hand sign
oh my god so it is that acute what I
guess it's worth mentioning like all the
tick-tock stuff this week has just been
this squared face guy but it's xxx sent
us you own it's copyrighted music in the
background I can't use it
alright let's just move on I just it
needs like a little you know what you
did it
you became tick tock famous
congratulations
next time here's a non copyrighted music
goddammit
nacho kitty real tired what the ink that
what the why what what so stupid is this
what kids are doing these days huh they
should be outside playing not sticking
their tongue out disgusting
not to be racist or anything but agent
people tact damn well I think this is
pretty solid evidence that had tick tock
is in fact vine to literally recreated
what the hell not to be racist ah how do
you make that sound how do you ah how do
you do that I mean I'm impressed
Waymon sometimes a in fresh meat don't
quote me on that
hey bro Chad Jake
judge check ha ha
president of Chad the population is
increasing
but you can hear going up every Chad
check everyone
Chad check Chad the grit literally looks
like Chad oh I never thought of that
this changes everything is that why Chad
it's Chad
I this brings a whole new perspective to
the meme
[Applause]
[Music]
stop it stop it dr. Phil for me and
review anyone it's much like if you want
it it can happen he sit
it's literally out there if enough
people smash like dr. Phil will come out
and host me review basically me okay so
you know the bigger shoe size the bigger
penis and of course yeah it's
proportional exactly and then the bigger
car that's smaller the penis okay but
what's your point
so clowns have huge actually learn
something today clowns have huge Jesus
Christ what is that lol why am i dolphin
networking think there may be a murderer
in my room can you help me find him
sorry I said him I should have said them
how am I supposed to know that it's a
guy I'm really sore at tick-tock you
should check their Twitter profile cuz
they will say he them or her or whatever
okay because that clearly needs to be
stated in case oh god anyone makes a
mistake
hey bro judge a judge check check
[Music]
but what is the GPD of chad oh my god
dude Chad come on Chad come on Chad Chad
is the only country that can save us
from India let's get real here let's
increase the gross domestic product of
Chad let's make it happen if this video
gets enough likes then it can happen now
I don't normally do this but anyone that
bites the merch I will donate to chat
that is a complete lie and false
statement but I will do it another not
really Tik Tok but still kind of Tik Tok
the absolute man whamon bail of dead
person lol why is my door Thank You Bell
tells been very cool now I can use her
in the thumbnail for millions of extra
abuse thank you to help Elfie this is a
blessing also thanks for not striking my
thumbnails I really appreciate it thank
you very much
[Music]
yeah only if you surprised PewDiePie
can you go out with the whamon if a wham
and ask you out you gotta ask her in
following question
oh you subbed or not and if she says yes
well then sup again ah you're joking
Thanks what hit or miss I guess they
never miss huh I told you next time you
say hit or miss I will not miss for a
tektite life hey it's another painting
time I'll take it ain't gonna happen
kiddo okay
[Music]
it's a human literally this happen
yeah
[Music]
hell yeah tan there well done well done
I will never ever play for night ever
again this is what happens when I'm
thinking raging for tonight I break my
freakin whole DVD man the cringe dude
this is what happens this is the
consequences alright that's it for this
week's tick-tock hope you guys enjoy
this video smash like force my main
spunky out of here for helping us
discover that's all for me see you guys
tomorrow
bye bye no brofist you know you have we
have a goal to work on itself - there
will be brofist are you looking at